plus de 30000 km de lignes entretenir
une météo extrêmement capricieuse des
millions de clients qui dépend de vous
la marge d'erreur d'hydro-québec est
mince
le réseau via les réseaux de plus en
plus sollicités puis on vise à maintenir
les plus aux paroles fiabilité donc ce
qu'on doit faire c'est d'être plus
efficace dans l'inspection des réseaux
de transport depuis une douzaine
d'années l'irec a mis au point plusieurs
robots pour évaluer l'état de ces lignes
de haute tension
des robots qui détecte la corrosion ou
l'usure des conducteurs d'autres équipés
de capteurs de caméras et d'un bras
mécanique qui peut serrer et des serrer
les boulons laisser le petit dernier le
line rangers qui retient maintenant
l'attention l'irec travail sur ce
prototype depuis trois ans plus sympa
manipuler et plus rapide que son
prédécesseur le line manager peut
franchir des obstacles avec une facilité
déconcertante qui en une seule journée
il peut inspecter jusqu'à une vingtaine
de kilomètres de lignes sous tension on
est en mesure de faire de l'inspection
visuelle très précises peut aller
chercher de l'information de la mesure
sur la température la résistance électro
d'autres indices sur l'intégrité
mécanique et encore une fois tu sors
sans interruption sauf l'irak a
également réussi à développer un drone
bourrés d'électronique et de systèmes de
télécommunications mais capable de se
poser sur une ligne de ses 135 mille
vols active qui transporte un courant de
milan perd un véritable tour de force
les deux technologies seront bientôt
prêtes à être commercialisées les robots
qu'on développe chez hydro québec ont
garé à succès national parce que les
grands réseaux électriques sont soumis
aux mêmes pressions qu'ils au québec on
pourra voir le live messenger et son
double en réalité virtuelle au festival
de la robotique de montréal qui débute
aujourd'hui ici normand grondin radio
canada montréal